people everything that you put online is
going to be hacked into or someone is
gonna get it that you don't want to get
it or the government is gonna get it or
the NSA is gonna get it or anonymous is
gonna get it or something like that this
time of course it's snapchat you've
probably heard about this already a
third party snapchat client called snap
saved was hacked into this week and
about 90,000 snaps were hacked and about
six thousand I'm sorry nine thousand
videos were stolen we've got a little
bit more info for ya the file was first
posted online via viral pop com which is
a bogus website thousands of people
downloaded the large file of stolen
photos and videos which was shared like
crazy on 4chan and reddit most of the
affected users are from Europe which
make up about a third of its overall
audience and the victims are split
fairly between males and females and
much of the content is explicit in
nature also a lot of the content might
be underage so now there's all kinds of
other legal issues that are gonna arise
out of this so of course the first
question any time we do anything on this
are you surprised
I mean we talk about this all the time
between the hacking and the NSA and
everything else does this surprise you
somebody got into snap not anymore
I mean I remember when this was
surprising stuff and we were all
terrified no my god how could this
happen how could you invade somebody's
privacy like this but no how can you be
surprised anymore Jennifer Lawrence said
you know I hope you you know cowards
cower in the corner and you're horrible
and you should be ashamed of yourself
and now that celebrities are saying it
you know I think people are paying
attention but are we surprised that
somebody illegally downloaded a file and
put it on everybody's snapchat website
or app which is an app so like basically
little kids can send a picture of their
boobs to other people and hope it's
gonna disappear yeah I'm not surprised
not surprised you know the other thing
Jimmy are you on the snapchat I mean it
doesn't disappear you can't believe it
you can't believe you're kidding Wow
well what you think it I'll never be
president now that's it unless they
don't mind a self fellating president
anyway the point is there's an image for
you uh no this is great
about what they shared it on 4chan which
have a goatee when I had a double chin
but what's the question the question is
can you believe it I mean like I'm just
appalled that somebody hacked in the
next you know the next thing you're
gonna tell me first of all how is this
y2k gonna work out I'm still worried
about that but yeah the next thing you
gonna tell me is that the government is
reading my emails yes of course that
means everybody everything's public
anymore anything you put on your phone
and forget about it I you know yeah okay
and it's getting harder and harder to
feel sympathy for people because this is
so common you have to protect yourself
and it's not by doing extra layers of
security on your computer it's about you
don't take naked pictures everybody
should take it we should all take a
snood selfie of ourselves and put it out
put it up there so that this is over
with completely agree that don't you
think that that Gia's gonna do it right
now that would be bad should have cut
away I've done this was about to be our
most viewed video ever Jimmy you could
do it too I don't I'll do it they would
be that but is there a little difference
with snapchat because it's skews so
young so it's like so the sympathy thing
that you don't have the sympathy maybe
for adults that realize what's going on
here but this really is 13 year old kids
I was on snapchat literally I got it for
like three days I posted my snapchat
on Twitter and people were just sending
me stupid pictures mostly of their
phrases with crazy phrases but yeah and
it was kids mostly so I was like alright
I'm done with this so there's a little
sympathy though for kids because they're
just getting it and they don't know they
don't really realize of course yeah I
don't know man I'm not a parent and so
in my mind I'm the best parent because I
don't have any kids so of course I do it
better than people with carbon-based
children yeah but I'm just wondering
like how do you how does it how do you
let it get to that and I don't know
because I'm not a parent and there are
little free little will Minds will do
whatever they want but they're taking
pictures of the butts the taking
pictures of the penises of take a
picture everything that are going oh my
god what have I done now everyone in
Middle School's seen it I don't know
what you do just stop doing that yeah
Jimmy if you had kids what would you do
because every kid now my four-year-old
nephew
an iPad like all these kids have this
stuff that you can't stop them right how
could you really stop them from
downloading an app that you can't watch
these kids 24 hours a day i donate for
that I've asked people with kids about
this the genies out of the bottle you
know I mean your kid has a computer it's
all over with everything they have
access to all porn I mean I can't I
don't know how people breaks kids today
I don't have a kid I went email up my
dog on the computer and you know it's
sad when I was a Disneyland yesterday
with a six-year-old a beautiful innocent
little six-year-old who is trying to
explain her Kindle to Tinkerbell but and
God bless Tinkerbell she goes what is a
Kindle is that the name of a fairy and
she's like no it's my Kindle like why
does this a and I get it it's awesome
it's technology it's amazing but it
makes me a little sad yeah are you guys
on overload with all this stuff because
yeah it's hit me that like I go to
overload calm I feel like that's
probably important site overload is
something else in there
no really I'm like totally overlooked
like I love Twitter of course that's my
main thing and then I'm not sure which
one is laughing overload cough is a
different thing I want to know what
overload calm is everyone I'm focusing
on the load part it's important thing
okay we got like for me it's like I love
Twitter we're doing this on Facebook of
course I'll do the Instagram once a day
but I can't take anymore
I officially cannot take anymore you on
board I'm sorry then I can't take
Facebook anymore I am so sick and tired
of finding out all the different ways
that my friends are racists and [ __ ]
it's like oh I didn't know you were an
[ __ ] thanks for this test that is I
had a guy the other day sort of got her
talk about the Adrian Peterson thing you
know he whipped his kid on the genitalia
it was no big deal he's a he's a great
guy yes he was raised different culture
and but there was a guy in Facebook
going oh I'm glad my parents beat me
because kept me out of prison
I'm like you ever been to prison just
filled with people who weren't hit
enough kids Oh bunch of college spoiled
[ __ ] say you know what they all
say it their trials hey it's my fault
spare the rod spoil the child
yes
put me away well I guess there at the
end of the day it's like we're not
supposed to know this much about
everyone Yeah right like that's the key
to this whole thing it's reprehensible
if you read their diary yeah alright
final thought in this room you guys see
this you write that one down that's good
hello that's the new one now that's
they're trying to it's gonna be a
minimalist no ads but I so like I saw it
so many but I had to sign up because I
was like I don't know if this thing's
gonna blow up so I got hello doc so
that's Dave Rubin you better follow me
on there because
[Music]